let's take a closer look at this and
other stories with Kevin's really chief
Washington correspondent for Bloomberg
News
he's also the anchor of Bloomberg radio
sound on Kevin good morning it's great
to be here so let's start with the
president continues to ratchet up his
his tough talk on legal immigration last
week it was we can't take you any more
this week it's we're sending you all the
sanctuary cities how a Republican
lawmaker is sitting with us well you
know it depends on which Republicans you
ask you know I was speaking with senior
sources and two lawmakers in the Senate
there's been uneasy especially some of
these lawmakers who are up for
re-election in 2020 but on the flip side
of that Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell actually signaling that
potentially he might be open to bringing
some type of immigration package in the
three months between now and the August
recess but that said Jared Kushner was
up on the hill with the president's
chief of staff Nick Mohini they met with
a group of Democrats but there's a lot
of divisiveness to put it mildly on the
issue of them is there any common ground
that they can work on on the issue of
some economic aspects of the immigration
debate the manufacturing community which
definitely has president Trump's ear has
definitely been urging Tucson to find
some type of middle ground on this but
in an era where Stephen Miller crafted
in the more Steve Banta desk wing of the
Trump ideology has emerged it within the
Trump administration is another leading
voice it's gonna be difficult to see how
why Democrats would want to work on an
issue like that with them this past week
we've also seen the upheaval at the top
of the HS what's going on at the cabin
Matt Kalinin is the current acting
director now of replacing former
secretary Neilson
but it's interesting with Kevin McHale
in him because he does have the respect
of the hardliners within the Trump
administration but if you go back to a
speech he gave at the Bipartisan Policy
Center last summer in 2018 he was quite
critical of some of the policies that
secretary Nielsen had endorsed most
notably cutting off aides to Honduras
Guatemala and El Salvador now Secretary
of State from paio this week came out
and said that he was on board with that
so we're still in a waiting to see mode
for how they they all fit together the
Trump administration not always agreeing
or appreciating shall we say that type
of disparity yeah
on the issue of this pardon of joke no
joke
I mean but does it really matter is it a
moot point well I think at this point it
really has become that just because of
all of the and all of the divide that
you've seen on that front this week the
Attorney General testified before the
House Appropriations Committee and said
he's getting ready to release a redacted
version of the mauler report what do you
what do we expect
I need a now you know I was at that
hearing and following that hearing I
interviewed the chairwoman of the
committee need Aloe a Democrat from New
York and she said essentially it's not
going to be good enough Democrats are
pushing for the complete full release
unredacted version of this report
Republicans are saying well if it
relates to national security or if there
were aspects of the investigation that
have to be redacted they ought to be but
chairwoman loi telling me essentially
they might have to use subpoena power I
was gonna say what links will they go
and that obviously being the most
extreme one of the things we heard is
that the Attorney General testified that
spying did occur people were surprised
then there was some backtrack you'll
have a sense now of where this is
there's an investigation into the
investigation and polls suggest I mean
it's like but polls suggest that that
Republicans want that that the
conservative base wants to see that they
feel that that this was an unfair
investigation as the president of Sweden
a quote-unquote witch-hunt yeah and now
that and that timeline for that will
likely be within the next couple of
months so 20 now in the Democratic field
it raised on residents I want to get on
that campaign trail right questions what
are you following yeah there's like
everyone everyone's running for
president these days people to judge
formally likely going to announce
tomorrow in Indiana and she's been in a
back-and-forth with the former with the
current vice president Mike Pence it's
been interesting to see how that dynamic
has played out he's perceived as a
rising star a great personal story but
you know he's got it'll be interesting
to see which type of Democrat and an
economic message he starts to espouse
it's still no joke
[Laughter]